so I'm not sure if that was like a
solution or not it sounded like it so
yeah there you had me going for a second
there and then ran out of gas or
something
[Music]
so we're going to start with this one
right here this was played by two very
strong players and white just made the
last move which is why in this current
position black's queen is hanging so
white just played the move Bishop from
d4 d5 hitting the Queen and naturally
expected some reply with the Queen and
then I think he was gonna deal with the
fact that his rook on I ate was hanging
or is hanging and basically you would
have a position with two bishops but
otherwise completely equal but Bishop e5
unleashed the possibility for black to
strike back tactically in this game so
looking at this position here I have to
move Bishop e5 it's black to move and I
think some problems some tactics you
look at and it says you know white to
play or white to move in and win in
three or win material or checkmate in
two I never liked those because it seems
like when you're when you're in an
actual game you don't ever get that that
benefit no one says okay well stop what
you're doing and you know you can win
and two moves because then I think I
would never miss a tactic ever that
would be nice but I like to have tactics
that are just well black to play and win
because that leaves it more open-ended
and if you say black to move and
checkmate kind of know you're looking
for a mate win material you know you're
looking for that so I prefer just black
to play and win and that's what this
problem is right here yeah
so any even if you don't have the answer
your wrong answer may very well help
some of the other members of the
audience and find the correct solution
so we're just working on the thinking
process what we play is black.here and
and why it might work front row
right so black can play rook takes rook
here our queen is hanging so Bishop
takes Queen and you'll play rook takes
rook and in that position if I play King
f2 are you gonna move your rook
somewhere because you're right you're
getting two ropes for the Queen and most
of the time two works for the Queen we
say in chess is a little bit better for
the rooks
sometimes the queen is better sometimes
the rooks are better you play what rook
F one and then if I took your rook on f1
and if I didn't take your rook on f1 and
I played King g3
she works in a bishop that's a little
different than two ropes because two
ropes I would argue is around even let's
say it's slightly better maybe for black
but you can do a bit better never work
f1 I'm sorry mm-hmm yep that's a detail
rook takes he ate was suggested rook
take c1 and this is this is all ready to
ROK's for the piece okay we could move
our rook back but you know that's not
really the end of the tactic that's not
overly impressive Brooke f1 was the
footer of the email from the front row
here if King takes well Knight e3 check
and takes here and if we take back we've
also got this we're up a full rook there
so that's definitely good if white
doesn't take that rope because he sees
this fork coming in with 93 King g3 well
we can take this bishop on c7 now we
don't just have two ropes but you have
two rooks you also have a knight so if
we were gonna have a debate about
whether to work so the Queen would be
better well now you just won the debate
he's you also have a knight so that's
too much I can't argue against that so
that's the solution not just rook e1 and
being satisfied with two ropes but also
important throwing in rook F 1 we have
the knight for coming on e3 next and
rook f1 also is a nice sort of desperado
where you make your rooks under attack
but you put it on square where it can't
be taken so kg 397 and then you have
this disposition which would be which
would be winning so yes you're good
that's correct
Kinki to now I'm probably looking to
give a check and again if King takes
rook we would probably have Knight e3
and if the King went somewhere that
wasn't attacking my Brooke probably the
same principles would apply that applied
last time when the King was on g3 so
anywhere that's not attacking that rook
all of a sudden I have this 97 move
coming in so let's say King d2 d3
well d2 makes it a little easy rook f2
so let's say here now while there might
be moves like rook III or other moves
let's just say the simplest is to say
Knight takes c7 and we have the same
thing where we've got two rooks and a
knight so it seems like White's kind of
in trouble no matter what but yes if if
white plays King you two we would have
to be a little bit cautious not to take
on c7 let's say with the the knight or
the rook because right now like this you
have this and if you take with the night
you don't have 93 any more so now I
could take your rook so a few details
let's say in every line that actually
matter for the solution but the bottom
line is you take those two rooks and
then we've got this nice Czech rook F 1
so Bishop e5 was actually just a blunder
in this position black played rook e8
and went on to win the game all right
well let's move on
this is a position from another game and
the first question is does anyone know
what the game is I'd be impressed
sometimes Pat tactics from games are so
famous that you see the tactic position
and you already know the game and if
that's the case I need to know now so I
never pick you for the answer all right
so we have some Liars in the room that's
good all right it's black to play it's
black to play and what I like to do is
well you know instead of you know black
to move inmate black move it the other
thing I like to say is that in this
position it's it's first of all black to
plain win but I like to have the whole
line so if you can do your best to
calculate in your head then when you
present an answer
you're not just saying one move and then
I say another and then you come up with
one move so if you can calculate the
whole thing there'll be a lot better for
improving practicing tactics think
that's always the way you should do it
because when you're playing a chess game
you don't get to play one move and then
they play a move and you know you get to
take back and try again
so you got to be sure if you're your
answer the same way you might be sure if
you're playing a chess game and you have
this position so black to play there's a
few ideas floating around in this
position but one thing of course we have
to note is that black is in fact down
one full rook and it's saying there are
B 1 for white so you can be sure that in
this position you probably need to go
for something quite forcing otherwise if
we trade trade trade down an endgame
I've got that extra rook so how do we
bail ourself out here with tactics as
black and again the full variation would
be nice but see see if you can calculate
as far as you can in your heads and and
then suggest suggest an answer once
you've once you've got a variation put
together
that's good way to approach
and as I said anything that you say
whether it's right or wrong is probably
gonna help your comrades arrive at the
answer as well so it can be a team
effort it's not a pump fake yep check me
so flat if black spawn ends up on g2 no
matter what I recapture on g2 with let's
not forget I've got that Bishop up in
the corner on a a there's gonna be
pinning it so I'll always have Queen
down f1 mate so that's a variation that
does make me which probably means that
let's say if you're calculating in your
head this variation he takes f3 we would
probably not play rook takes p2 so white
would need another move because rook b2
does get mated by force after pawn takes
on g2 yep well II fgf right there's a
few things first of all II fgf not only
can i play Queen takes g4 full Queen
Bishop takes f3 almost full Queen Queen
takes be one full rook so black has
three good options spoiled for choice so
after each takes f3 sometimes the
hardest part of tactics actually finding
out what you're supposed to play for
your poor opponent but so far we've only
recommended losing variations so how
about a better move for white if we're
gonna calculate this e takes f3 line
uh-huh
you wet
well why did you stop there uh-huh
right so I'm not sure if that was like a
solution or not it sounded like it so
yeah there you had me going for a second
there and then ran out of gas or
something but maybe maybe you you you
can have someone pick you up on the road
and you know pick up where you left off
did you guys listen to that variation so
the first thing is that Queen a5 is it
may be a much better move for white
somehow we've we finally arrived it may
be a decent move for white which is if
pawn takes f3 Queen takes f5 and it
would take on g2 so that was the line
and then White's got only one move so
King to g1 and then Bishop d4 and then
Queen back to f2 and that's where our
friend ran and I guess this doesn't
necessarily mean that the line is right
but that's the position that he arrived
in if there's anything there for black
that might be helpful otherwise you
might need a new variation but if you
can visualize that position it was
Bishop d4 and then Queen back to f2 for
white because if you're not gonna take
my Queen well I'm gonna use it to block
that that checkmate idea so II takes f3
Queen takes f5 maybe their other moves
but the line was pawn takes g2 King g1
we all liked Bishop D for saving the
black bishop on b2 and maybe using it
for the attack but after Queen f2 or
rather stumped because well yeah if you
take my queen on f2 King takes f2 let's
remember in the starting position I have
full extra Brooke so you'd have to win
some substantial material in order to be
able to just play an endgame
so if Bishop takes f2 King takes f2
there you only have a bishop in a knight
left and I still have three pieces in a
row so you have to be careful not to
just I mean okay can't just trade trade
trade a bunch of pieces because we don't
have that many to start with are there
any other ideas because we either feel
like we're on the right track and we
must be missing something in this
variation or we could just be on the
wrong track and it's the wrong radiation
the back okay Queen takes out five
kingi wine you could do it you takes F
that's one line that we didn't say so
far but what I was saying is remember at
the start you're already down one rook
so if you just take my queen back
problem is I'll go take your Bishop rook
takes b2 now I'm up a row I'm up a
bishop temporarily but that's enough
material so you got to make sure you
have a follow up to that at least
I feel like you might not be surprised
if I said you were close in the back
again
okay and you want to play next move what
uh-huh and then when you Queen your pawn
I'm gonna have to take it right and then
you're gonna take me back and I know
it's a lot of work but if you visualize
that position let's say that I move my
bishop from f8 let's say I save it after
Knight f4 let's say Bishop d6 then when
you go and Queen your pawn I give up my
rook I'm gonna have Bishop b3 Knight a 2
and my Bishop down here you're only
gonna have two pieces your knight in
your Bishop so even after all that hard
work remember I'm still up a piece there
so that would still be losing for you
yeah Knight f4 Queen and of Queen takes
d4 the knight h3 is check me so
we had this position for a while but it
it can be hard to visualize all the
squares that are available are
unavailable but Knight f4 here threatens
night going to h3 checkmate so if we
play Queen takes d4 we get mated
surprisingly only with I mean upon a
knight and a bishop but Knight h3 is so
powerful here it just has to be stopped
so why doesn't have an option he doesn't
have a choice to play like Queen takes
t4 you can't get rid of the Jeep on
either because you're pinned so White's
the only real move here honestly is like
something like h4
so how would we finish off this Knight
h3 King h2
the reason we're still playing remember
is I do have that extra ruck so so
taking on f2 would be actually pretty
much the line that was suggested in the
back so [ __ ] back to King takes Knight
h3 and somehow I would end up up a piece
there miraculously so it looks like I'm
drawing dead here but I've got an extra
Brook so I think we still need to be a
bit precise here how do we finish it off
Knight f4 was the pretty move now this
is the this is the boring stuff but
still have to to finish off here 92 King
h2 Bishop e5 King h3 well now you're not
attacking my queen so I might just get
away there in front
kingi three take it
and then I saved my bishop from f8 and
remember you gotta count those pieces
I'm gonna have three of them write my
bishop from f8 I'm saving plus the other
two and you've only got two left
I mean we're so close as a unit we are
so close okay
King h2 yeah right
and you don't lose a minor piece in that
variation so not net h3 which were so
infatuated with that was the whole point
of Knight f4 but it did its job with h4
now 92 and just takes now when we Queen
we're gonna get the rook but we're also
going to keep all three of our pieces
and finally that's the winning in game
finally so every step of the way I think
most people here seem to to know the
themes we have to like put them together
why they're very literally called
puzzles in the right order because
they're not gonna work necessarily in
every order you know which moves are
correct but finally here at 92 is the
move that kind of slips under the radar
because we're so focused on a h3 that
was the point of net F work in this
position I think maybe the hardest move
is remembering that Knight f4 is
possible and that we can actually hang
our bishop in the middle of the board
because of this very strange night h3
checkmate so because of that blacks are
actually winning after Knight f4 and and
the line that we just showed is is the
end of it and yep this did all of this
happened a game and it it ended exactly
the way we just we just looked at 90 -
aah - Bishop takes and of course the I
mean played on it's not like just
resigned there but blacks gonna be up in
that position too ponds in end game plus
I mean none of whites pieces are really
placed that well and to be honest
White's king is still in trouble so yeah
that's that's that one it's it's he
takes f3 and then there's a few key
moves but Knight f4 and 92 at the very
end
we have this position now and oh it
already looks much less complicated than
the last one thank goodness but it's
white to play and win very simple white
to play Nguyen not as complicated we can
relax a little bit but I think it's
tricky nonetheless we have some ideas
here based on on the position but again
do your best to try to think of a
variation where you might give a move
for white and response for black and
hopefully reach an answer that way so
try to have the calculation all in your
head rather than one move at a time
because like I said that's how it works
when you're playing over the board too
so it's good practice
I think last example was probably the
best example of how everybody
contributing a little something
eventually we got to the answer no one
was able to get the whole thing start to
finish so that's why even if you're not
sure raising your hand and trying out
but definitely definitely help speaking
out of turn it's just I saw a hand back
there from a young mature boy yeah it
doesn't work okay what your hand was up
so that was better
hey you
ready - uh-huh mm-hmm
let me hear that full very yeah sure so
right so so rookie - first of all just
so everyone knows it might be helpful
for your own calculations rookie - was
the move suggested and then Queen take C
- so trying to deflect that Queen down
the board and then rook a8 into the
corner and then if Bishop takes a8 well
it's nice we get to bring our queen down
to b8 and even though I have like 19
points that I can throw in front of that
Queen it's not enough to stop it and
that will be a back rank mate the
problem is after rook e8 that Black has
two pieces on the c8 square so I can
pick one of them put it in front let's
say the bishop probably the better one
and unfortunately that position well and
we need another move for white or it
doesn't look like we're crashing through
but that was the that was the suggestion
doesn't quite work all right how about
you
okay so using his idea
rook e to Queen take c2 and you said
rook takes b7 mm-hm so you're right if
ruk takes b7 in that line if you guys
can visualize it rook takes b7 instead
of taking back I'm going to go clean d8
once again into a back rank mate did you
have another move for black instead of
rook takes rook mm-hmm
mm-hmm mm-hmm how about Queenie
rook to ca
shucks
but again the the variation suggested
was also rookie to again with some sort
of deflection idea but this time wanted
to play rook takes b7 but the reason
that the back rank may plus the rook can
be defend at the same time as I have
this move Queen it back to e8 and then
if rook b8 wrote back to c8 so
unfortunately that one doesn't work but
again it feels like we're very close
mm-hmm okay so rook takes b7 rook takes
b7 now rookie - and if rope takes your
queen on b6 right and then now it's my
turn with nothing threatened so I'll
play move like h6 for example and
there's no way if my pieces were hanging
then there might be a double attack but
you've actually sacked a rope to get
there so yeah then in the final position
I would just be out material so even
flipping the moves doesn't work
sometimes it does was just talking about
how you got to put the puzzle in the
right order so that's that's a pretty
logical guess here in the front
Queen takes p7 so same thing rook e -
Queen takes you to Queen takes b7 first
of all rook takes your queen right and
then no matter what I throw in front of
you you're just like the kool-aid man
just breaking through every wall all
right
so I don't take your queen now I don't
have let's say Queenie 8 because I've
actually got a whole rope hanging with
d7 by both of your pieces so what about
rook D 8 from d7 mm-hmm Queen takes f7
is hanging there so by playing Queen
takes b7 we're not only threatening the
rook not only threatening the back rank
but that wasn't enough in your last
guess right because I had Queen e8 but
we've added a third thing we're
threatening here which is the seventh
ring Queen days B 7 suddenly were
threatening Queen takes f7 Queen g7 mate
so that would be what we need Queen
takes b7 and again this move was saving
us last time but it doesn't anymore
that's a free Brooke we're gonna be up
at night and okay up at night in a pond
by the way this Knight is kind of a hero
as well because it's been covering this
checking square in in every single line
here and if black could have ever ever
checked it would be very bad I mean
there'd be hanging stuff everywhere so
that night is kind of a hero and Queen
b7 is very nice move at the end sort of
I felt like everyone's answers was sort
of how my brain would work if I was
calculating it my first guess would be
like okay why don't I sack the Baroque
and play rock a8 and try to meet okay
that doesn't work why don't I try to do
this and take the bishop with the rook
that doesn't work and then maybe
eventually you realize you need one more
threat which is on the seventh rank
sometimes it's possible to defend two
things at once but it's often very
difficult to defend three things at once
so Queen takes b7 was that extra extra
idea we needed to to solve this one so
yeah it's just simply rookie to Queen
takes and Queen takes b7 all right now
this one is also from a game in fact
and aside about problems is that I
always like to do problems that are
generally from games because I think
they're very realistic obviously they're
from games but it's nice to do puzzles
or problems that existed or happened in
a real game because first of all it
means you got there by legal moves a lot
of problems you know you just put the
pieces on the board but maybe that will
never ever happen in a game and so
you're basically just practicing a
pattern when you do problems that are
from games not only in practicing a
pattern but you're getting used to
something that you may actually see
again a position similar to that and
right here we have a position where it's
white to move so white to plain win and
it looks like a position that's that's I
mean very easy to believe came from a
real game black obviously has a bit of
an exposed King but so does white so
things have gotten a little crazy in
this one and black obviously just played
the move Queen to f6 blocking a check
from d4 and white to move has to deal
with the fact that next move you know we
have moves like f2 check coming and I
think at the moment we can even say the
black is up upon so it's white - playing
win we've got to take our time here this
could be an actual this could happen to
you in your games what would you play as
white
where do some ideas that are flowing
around in the room
right well right because one of the most
glaring things about the position is
that the the Queen is hanging on on d4
so whatever we do we're required to deal
with that either by some sort of forcing
move where we're hoping to make Queen
takes d4 a bad move so maybe let it
happen but it's a bad move or don't let
it happen and then you either have to
like block the Queen's exchanging the
Queen's we can already say probably
doesn't look like the solution because
there's no there's no follow-up and and
rook one the e5 was was the idea here so
bringing this rook from e1 here yeah up
to e5 threatening rook takes g5 one of
the bonuses of that move is it sort of
deals with F to check for black because
then we could just step out of the way
like King King g2 whereas if we made
another move maybe f2 even if white
could take it well
if we trade the Queens off we could
probably say that's not answer to the
tactic because we just wouldn't have any
firepower left
so rook 1 to e5 may be something to
consider not really a follow up to it
but it does threaten brooke g5 probably
after rookie 5 moves to to consider
would be you know maybe black moving his
King somewhere like potentially King f8
or King
yeah maybe King f8 I think King f8 is
probably what I
might suggest against that
yeah
so did you say Queen f6 it was the first
one so white playing Queen f6
okay so trading the Queen's and black
takes it back do you know what you want
to do after that that's fine you don't
have to that's why it's good to say it
out loud because if you play Queen takes
Queen what I was thinking is that after
I play King takes Queen the reason why
it might be tough to find a move is well
you don't have your Queen on the board
anymore and a queen is such a powerful
piece that you might need it to deliver
either a check me or for any of the
tactics that you want to work so you
always got to be careful when you're
doing puzzles if you ever play move it
just trades your Queen off not that it's
always wrong but that if you trade your
Queen off you better have a lot of other
pieces that you can attack with so one
of the things is if you play Queen takes
Queen King takes Queen the kings on a
dark square you have a light squared
Bishop here so you know that that Bishop
can't check the King and the only square
that the rooks can check from would be
e6 and you're gonna lose more material
Bishop takes rook if you check there so
because of that I would say probably you
want to look for moves that keep your
queen on the board and you might need
her to to deliver some some kind of
checkmate or tactic but yeah be careful
about trading off the Queen's in the
back
okay well you left me without a choice
so if you play rock up seven I've got to
play King tags and then after Queen a7
first of all what about King to g6
rookie six is going to win my queen so
queen a7 King g6 rookie six so what
about King f8 instead of king g6 rookie
six still not winning my queen this time
but let's say rook e six I've got to
move my queen thankfully for white with
the Queen down there on a seven you
notice that the diagonal to my king is
actually covered so that's very
important actually that I don't have
like a queen d4 check in any line so
after rook e6 hitting my queen let's say
queen
first of all Queen f4 hmm well you have
better
Queenie seven would be made there and so
Queen f7 to stop your checkmate Queen c5
and then square that I would love to
move my king - maybe f7 is taken what
about King g7 well you've got a pawn on
d5 don't forget sometimes the most
annoying pieces and are your own okay
why are you why are you there need you
so that pawn on d5 means there's no
Queen going across the board on the
fifth-ranked
sorry
are you in the same position
so after queen c5 King g7 uh-huh
rookie seven it's going to be skewering
my queen on f7 - my king on g7 that's
correct yeah so Rick f7 is is the move
that I think when you approach this
problem you should be calculating first
reason is because not only is it it
checked but it sort of brings the king
out into the open where the rest of our
pieces could try to attack it so rook
takes f7 Queen's pinned and it's also
checked so there's no Queen d4 this moon
is forced Queen a7 because we really
don't have any other checks black
unfortunately for him can't play rook d7
or Queen e7 nothing to block it and the
King only has two squares to go so it's
actually not the longest calculation
that we've had to do King g6 is nice
because just rook b6 but easy skewer
there and King f8 is probably the more
difficult one because there's not a not
a forced sequence here like after rookie
six Black has options where to move his
Queen so we don't get that feeling that
it's very forced maybe that's why rookie
six it's probably the trickier moved to
find in this tactic rookie six and we've
got a checkmate in one on e7 so black
just has to play Queen f7 or Queen g7
and simply no matter which one he
chooses there's going to be something
wrong with it Queen g7 Queen c5 Queen a
7 that's a mate
and Queen f7 as we recently discovered
after Queen c5 King g7 not Queen g5 but
rookie seven is actually the same idea
that we've been using in most of these
lines which is that the rook eventually
will find a way to skewer the king or
the the Queen to the king its rookie
seven and black is just down a bishop
basically because we had a problem
actually earlier where we were
evaluating two ropes for a queen and
that's that's reasonable that's that's
fine I wouldn't say that you're ever
gonna win a tactic puzzle by by doing
that but when you add an extra piece in
then then it's too much
so rook and a piece I wrote two ropes in
a piece or queen and a piece are going
to be better than than their
counterparts so yeah
rookie 7 and then the queen is just
skewered and that's that so this one
this is not sure actually if I could
tell you this is from our game from a
game or not but I can say that it's
equally as valuable because it certainly
looks like it could be so it's not some
sort of random position with you know
like two bishops on the same color or
something absurd you could get this in a
real game and we've got even material
here one thing we could say about blacks
position is it appears as though he
might be better just because he's got
the two bishops but he's actually faced
with a bit of an issue here is that his
Queens attacked on c6 and although it
might not look nice for for white here
with all those weaknesses if black moves
his Queen somewhere safe White's gonna
take the knight on e4 and just be up a
piece so maybe white has has sort of
committed all these you know
gastly weaknesses around his King
because he thought he was winning a
piece here
Knight e5 was the last move attacking
the black Queen and the black Queen
seemingly doesn't have any squares
available to keep defending the knight
on e4 so that's the basis of the tactic
it's black to play and well not just
lose and let that happen
in the back I was quick
okay now what's your ID with 95
okay so simply 95 Bishop takes g5 Queen
G to mate is the the simple one
obviously everyone myself what happens
like that's just like fell off what
happens when I take your queen okay
that's cute
what about if I was not so cooperative
because I like your calculation that's
really quick really good but 95 what if
I was maybe just as good as you in
calculating and I saw all that and I
said I don't want this kid to embarrass
me
so I played f4 after an a g5
Knight takes f3
queen f2
I mean hey I might like your position
but are you winning remember at the end
of the day there we do have equal
material so I like your position it
looks like a good position for black but
you're actually not even up one Pont
you're not even up one single plant and
I can tell you that unless you've got me
in a beautiful
zooks Wang or something that you
probably in the final position need to
be up some sort of material
and again for those that were wondering
about his calculation it should be
pointed out that what he said after 95
if I didn't play off four which is why I
said it was good well calculated is
Knight g5 if Knight takes Queen black
wants to play Knight from g5 to f3 check
forcing us to play King h1 and then
black playing Bishop to g2 check forcing
King takes g2 and then we play Knight
takes a one check King moves Knight
takes c2 and proposing that that line is
is winning so that was the reason why 95
was was played there but yeah Knight 9
g5 I think what I'll do is I'll play f4
and although Knight f3 looks like a nice
position for you I don't think I could
say that it's just winning how about in
the front
so same thing like same calculation
different square what do you think of 92
in the back yeah okay yeah I saw your
hand up as well because 92 whether
you're the guy who suggested that
variation or you just listen to it you
can see that most of this calculation
look pretty good that whole line look
good but then I'm able to just place f4
move and suddenly I don't suffer from
any of that so 95 f 4 we can deal with
that made by playing Knight d2 so we're
still threatening Queen g2 mate which
means that no matter what white is gonna
have to take our queen but we also don't
allow an f4 move because the Knight d2
if white plays out for then there's no
covering Queen g2 mate that's exactly
why the knight will sit on d2 and block
the Queen on c2 from from covering it so
now if we actually look at that
calculation I think it's more forced
Knight d2 I have to take the Queen
Knight f3 check King h1 Bishop g2 King
takes g2 Knight takes a 1 King f1 let's
say Knight takes c2 but I don't think
the calculations over I'm gonna play
Knight take see 7 check right because my
knight was sitting on c6 there let's not
forget your King f8 Bishop takes c5
one thing about tactics when you're
playing them in your actual games is
after the tactic your opponent never
resigns when you're doing tactics it'll
say you know win material in four moves
so you'll play four moves you'll win
material and then you'll stop
calculating but in a game no matter if
your opponent is up or down material
unless it's a lot they're probably going
to keep playing which is why when you
calculate over the board you have to be
a little more careful than to just
imagine you're doing a tactic you have
to calculate usually further you have to
make sure that the final position when
you're done calculating is is very clear
maybe you're ahead material maybe
there's no more threats but leaving a
white knight on c6 in this position and
saying that's the end of your
calculation is a bit dangerous because
you've got a rook hanging there you've
got a bishop hanging you know we gave up
some material to have all these
beautiful calculation so you also got to
make sure you're counting in your head
make sure you're not down material I
mean who knows so you got to finish the
line so my Knights on c6 and we're gonna
try to do this in our head it's good
practice and I'm playing Knight take C
seven check at the end of this variation
King f8 and now I'm saying I'll play
them a bishop captures your pawn on c5
defending my knight may be setting up
some discovered check and we just have
to finish the calculation here so what
what do we do after that also does
anyone know what the material is in that
position because that's a good place to
start it's hard to really calculate the
best moves if you don't even know who's
ahead and material yeah in the front you
black takes the rook on e1 let's say
before you take the rook on a1 do you
know what the material is are you ahead
as black or what's going on there
right so there's a 97 an item b1 Bishop
on c5 Brooklyn a 1 for white got the two
ropes in the night on c2 for black and
your move is Knight takes 8 1 you said
right okay so now I'll play knight c6
check from my Bishop on c5 sorry King g8
let's say well Knight takes rook on d8
and in that position how's the material
in the back yeah black something
exchange we could also be a little more
clear and just say black stopping
exchange for a pawn because we did lose
that C pawn but yes being up in exchange
for the pawn they're probably good
good enough that's the type of position
that I think you should be ending your
calculation on when you can safely just
say okay he's not checkmate amis and
there's no more threats while in this
case maybe it wouldn't matter maybe you
get to that position and you hadn't
thought any further and okay it just
works out for you but I can say that
some calculations that you calculate
it's beautiful the whole thing and then
you get to a position and you hadn't cut
a calculated any further but maybe your
opponent has and that's the way you miss
things or that's the way something might
not work out for you
so 92 Knight takes c6 forest it's
important to play Knight d2 so there's
no f4 Knight f3 Bishop g2 okay so this
is the nice way to force the win of all
that material Knight takes check Bishop
takes again Knight takes rook 96
personally I would always say instead of
playing King g8 to play King e8 not that
it's very relevant to the tactic but we
should go towards the center if it's if
it's safe yeah in the back
right here in this position you could
play King here yeah probably the reason
that it feels natural for me to play
King f8 is because I I know that I can
force the win of the rook on a one or
the night only seven and Andy winning so
here if I played rook a - uh-huh mm-hmm
intake right yeah and yeah I think in in
this position it would also be be very
very good if I had to choose honestly a
position that that I would play I don't
know which one I'd choose cuz here I'm
not down the pawn but maybe this knight
on d5 is kind of like strong and
annoying but you're absolutely right
that you could play King h8 or King f8
so it wouldn't really matter to me in
terms of the answer which one you whiche
when you picked as long as you just
calculated it until the end where you
saw a position okay I want material
there that's winning so yes this is fine
this works
but the one we that we were looking at
right there was King f8 Bishop takes c5
Knight takes a1 check take back and in
this position just like the variation
that was presented by him we finally can
say okay you know there's no bishop
takes a seven because because rook d1
right and we lose more material so white
has to spend time going Knight c3 and
black will play a6 b6 something to keep
the pawn get the knight out next move
and it's all all fine here so both of
those are winning but King f8 or King h8
more so a bit of preference maybe once
more accurate than the other but they're
both winning so as long as you reach an
end position like I said that you know
is better for you then you can stop your
calculation there but I think the one of
the keys early on to this problem was
actually the Knight g5 move early was
was enough to probably help us out
because we actually saw that this move
worked except for f4 so once you see
that or once you calculate that in your
head then you start looking for ways to
stop f4 because you know if you stop f4
then the whole tactic works so that's
how you stumble on the fact that 92
would be the right move
so f4 doesn't exist as those made here
and then the rest of the tactic is all
is all good after night c6 we saw what
happens so yeah this is this is winning
for black after 92 and actually he came
across 95 pretty fast I don't even think
I finished giving my speech and you're
all he hit me with 95 so not quite the
right move but I think you know work
together to pretty much figure out
Knight d2 was was the correct move there
so yeah I just prepared those 5 tactics
actually so I mean that's that's
technically it for for now guys but some
things when I'm solving tactics that
always like to do and I think I've
mentioned them here but more so to
reiterate is first of all to you know
calculate the whole variation because
anytime you calculate bits and pieces
the bits and pieces you're not
calculating hour
gonna be what we call blenders I mean if
you ever not calculating part of it and
you just feel like it's gonna work out
that's where you're gonna make mistake
of course so you want to calculate fully
you want to do it all in your head when
you're doing these puzzles moving the
pieces is a bad habit because it's all
going to be visual when you're faced
with the tactic in a chess game anyway
so it should all be visual when you're
when you're practicing like it's a
wouldn't make much sense to practice
under different conditions than the
actual game for you know almost any
support so yeah yeah that's it for today
guys but thanks for coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]